bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous avons parlé d'un sujet qui sera
dans quelques jours au coeur de
l'actualité il s'agit du sida avec une
nouvelle édition du sidaction qui débute
ce vendredi pour se poursuivre samedi et
dimanche l'occasion de faire un point
sur le virus un point sur la maladie où
en est-on dans la recherche la fin du
sida est pour bientôt ou dans longtemps
pour répondre à ces questions en plateau
avec moi le professeur bertrand auvert
enseignants santé publique à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
le docteur benoît couderc médecin
consultant centre gratuit d'information
de dépistage et de diagnostic du centre
hospitalier de meulan les mureaux en
face de vous car la grossesse étudiante
et coréalisatrice du film alma 22h15
pour le concours vih pocket films et
puis jérôme andré directeur da chef
prévention une association de prévention
comme son nom l'indiqué bonsoir à vous
quatre je vous conte pause avant de vous
donner la parole vous propose de voir de
l'un des spots qui sera diffusé dans le
cadre du sidaction d'un des trois spots
qui sera diffusée tout de suite
laura ça fait trois ans qu'on bosse dans
le même bureau
tu vois j'aimerais j'aimerais vraiment
dire que si elle est toujours absente
c'est parce que c'est une grosse
feignasse
mais avec sa maladie elle a même plus le
courage de se lever avec le sida la vie
est beaucoup plus compliqué aidez nous à
vaincre le sida données au sein 10 ou
sur sidaction.org et malheureusement la
vie est beaucoup plus compliquée pour de
nombreuses personnes quelques chiffres
pour cadrer le débat le sida dans le
monde c'est 36,9 millions de personnes
atteintes par la maladie vous et les
chiffres 17 millions de personnes
atteintes sans le savoir dans le monde
5600 nouvelles infections par jour deux
morts par minute des chiffres qui font
froid dans le dos malheureusement en
france la situation n'est pas parfaite
non plus loin de là cent cinquante mille
personnes vivent avec le virus en france
et 30 mille
sans le savoir alors clairement quand on
lit ces chiffres faut-il être inquiet ou
alors ce sont des chiffres qui ont
tendance à s'améliorer malgré leur
nombre assez élevé on va faire un
premier tour de table en commençant par
vous bertran auvert professeur vous
allez travailler sur le sujet en afrique
ce sont des chefs qui sont pas
rassurants tout de même bah non ils sont
pas ils sont pas rassurants par exemple
aussi bien au niveau en france que
l'étranger en france qu'on regarde la
communauté hsh on voit que le nombre de
nouvelles infections par an n'a pas
beaucoup varié dans les dernières années
malgré toutes les campagnes de
prévention malgré tout les
investissements qui ont été faits donc
d'une certaine manière on n'a pas être
est optimiste on voit on voit en afrique
par exemple que l'épidémie est la bonne
at un plateau elle a commencé un petit
peu a diminué mais elle a diminué un
petit peu naturellement même si les
traitements sont relativement disponible
d'un certain nombre de cas a partout on
voit que c'est une épidémie qui n'est
pas vraiment ce contrôle on en parle
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont faits en progrès en particulier le
problème majeur c'est la prévention de
la transmission de la mère à l'enfant
et puis le fait que aux moeurs quasiment
plus du vih si on est traités
correctement on a une espérance de vie
identique mais ça c'est des chiffres
très ratio des des données extrêmement à
sion mais globalement quand même on peut
pas se satisfaire de la situation
situation actuelle c'est impossible
benoît couderc de nature je suis moins
alarmiste
je rappelle et je pense que c'est un
challenge où tout le monde doit
combattre l oms à 10,0 sida en 2030
c'est vrai et mon confrère a raison
c'est difficile parce que la société
fait que l'évolution on est il faut
combattre ces comportements harris et
surtout ce set nos volontés part de
dépistage effectivement je représente un
médecin de cegid
c'est une restructuration des centres de
dépistage aujourd'hui dans la prévention
et le dépistage pour pouvoir être été
plus tôt les recommandations font
contracte au déjà pour le patient parce
que l'on sait c'est bénéfique même s'il
reste c'est une maladie chronique à
prendre un traitement toute sa vie mais
aussi pour éviter de contaminer
donc je suis à un peu moins pessimiste
mais effectivement faut se réserver il
faut que tous ensemble les patients nous
les associations on participe à cet
effort à cette campagne de dépistage
très importante la germandrée votre
point de vue sur l'état des lieux sur ce
qui a été dit par un des premiers
invités
nous on a un regard un peu différent
puisque effectivement fait beaucoup de
dépistage en proximité vers les gens ce
qu'on appelle donc du hors les murs et
effectivement on avait dénoté depuis
deux trois ans on l'avait dit d'ailleurs
à plusieurs reprises sur téléphiles
qu'effectivement il y avait une vraie
reprise de l'épidémie sur certaines
populations effectivement les hommes qui
ont des relations sexuelles avec
d'autres hommes principalement mais pas
seulement
il ya aussi effectivement les publics
migrants les personnes qui viennent
notamment donc d'afrique essentiellement
sub sahara mais surtout les moins de 25
ans sont beaucoup touché aujourd'hui et
ça on en parle peu et c'est vrai que
pour le coup c'est important de le
rappeler les 18-25 ans sont énormément
touché et aussi les plus de 45 ans parce
que les plus de 45 ans c'est aussi une
période charnière où les gens changent
de comportement sexuel change de vie et
comme vous le savez effectivement à
chaque prévention intervient à la fois
sur ses publics jeunes mais aussi sur
les plus de 45 ans pour proposer donc du
dépistage du dipri stage donc de
proximité et puis récemment on avait
fait donc le lancement des autotests en
france vous souhaitiez peut-être réagi
rue
une nouvelle fois bertrand vert oui je
veux simplement rappeler quelques
chiffres en france je crois qu'il ya à
peu près six mille six cents nouvelles
infections par an ouais ce sont les
chiffres moyens d'action et sursee 6600
d'infections nouvelles par an il y en a
40 2% qui sont pour les hommes ayant des
rapports sexuels avec les hommes 39 %
pour les hétérosexuels nés hors de
france donc l'ensemble de ces catégories
fait à peu près 80% 17 % pour les
hétérosexuels nés en france et 1 % pour
l'usagé de drogues
voilà donc ça c'est à peu près donne une
image tout à fait celle que vous vous
disiez à ccc une image avec une
communauté à ses charges qui représente
quand même une part importante
je suis pas si je peux rajouter quelques
petites choses rapidement pour qu'on
puisse évoquer un autre sujet alors tout
à l'heure juste si on a cette impression
que les jeunes se relâche notamment
c'est aussi parce qu'on l'entend souvent
dans la presse dans les médias
un vaccin futuriste qui va tout
révolutionner c'était le cas récemment
il ya peut-être que semaine quelques
jours sur un vaccin que des chercheurs
français auraient trouvé et qui aurait
été efficace est ce que tout ça ce sont
des légendes des rumeurs aujourd'hui
soyons francs selon claire on ne guérit
pas encore du sida c'est surtout des
effets d'annoncé c'est à dire que faut
savoir que pour développer un vaccin on
a besoin d'argent
et effectivement le fait de pouvoir
annoncer comme ça dans les journaux
qu'un vaccin est en train de se faire
notamment sur marseille c'est quand même
une opération comme c'est une opération
de com mais c'est surtout préjudiciable
quand vous avez effectivement des gens
qui lisent dans la presse un vaccin est
en préparation qu'est ce qu'ils disent
ils se disent bon bah c'est bon
effectivement on va bientôt être
vaccinés sauf qu on ne vaccine pas la
population comme ça et le docteur von à
couderc en sait quelque chose puisqu'il
fait aussi beaucoup de vaccination dans
le pôle santé publique des yvelines
mais pour le coup on se rend bien compte
que le vaccin c'est pas pour demain
très clairement mais c'est surtout que
laisser croire aux gens qu'à vaccin est
en cours d'être fait ça pénalise la
prévention et nous on le voit sur le
travail d'actions de terrain parce que
globalement ça ça ça enlève une chance à
ce que des gens puissent effectivement
se dire la prévention c'est important
que
une prévention adaptées pour moi et que
je puisse me protéger et je rappelle
quand même que la prévention et le
dépistage
aujourd'hui c'est quand même les deux
piliers les plus forts en france pour
effectivement arrivé à éradiquer donc la
maladie moi j'aimerais juste te dire
qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi que
les professionnels de santé les
associations mais la population en
général innove en termes de prévention
santé il a je parle pas que du vih
aujourd'hui si les jeunes note un
relâchement c'est aussi parce qu'ils se
sentent pas concernés
le fait de ne plus mourir par le vih
parce que effectivement il ya de très
bons traitements mais les traitements ne
font pas tout ça engendre aussi le fait
de pouvoir se dire et bien effectivement
ce n'est pas très grave si je suis
contaminé une campagne comme le
sidaction
ça remet un peu les pendules à l'heure
dans le sens où effectivement ça peut
être compliqué d'être séropositif benoît
couderc vous partagez ce qui ce qui
vient d'être dit je voyais les partage
complètement je jurerais 1,6
effectivement sur aujourd'hui le virage
dans le virage parler cegid qui sont ces
centres restructurer pour le dépistage
comme le dit jérôme andré mais on va
être d'accord le virage sur la
prévention
aujourd'hui effectivement il ya des
moyens qui sont données pour la
prévention et ne pas être que dans le
curatif
parce qu'effectivement il faut éviter
ces contaminations et pour les éviter
faut dépister auront parlé des jeunes
effectivement qui sont des publics
cibles il faut absolument une éducation
à la santé globalement ce qu'on disait
est la plus particulièrement à la santé
sexuelle
donc le meilleur moyen c'est le
préservatif mais c'est aussi le
dépistage
parce que ça permet d'en parler et c'est
là dessus je suis optimiste parce qu'à
un moment donné faut dire aux jeunes
louis continue à porter le préservatif
c'est une maladie qui reste chronique
même s'il y un traitement et les
traitements sont beaucoup améliorées
vous avez parfaitement raison
le vaccin c'est pas pour aujourd'hui on
est dans le domaine de la recherche de
domaine de la recherche peut durer très
longtemps
mais même s'il faut continuer on a
besoin des chercheurs il ya d'autres ce
qui s'est beaucoup améliorée pour les
personnes vivant avec le vih c'est le
traitement
maintenant il faut travailler sur
l'observance du traitement et là on
espère dans la recherche avoir des
améliorations en corse pour aider le
patient vivant avec le vih à cette
observance
mais une des idées c'est la recherche
aujourd'hui on est plus que dans la
recherche fondamentale c'est de se dire
il faut diminuer cette épidémie il faut
dépister prévenir il faut que les gens
qui soient porteurs du vih
ça a été dit dans les chiffres viennent
se faire dépister tôt pour aeg traiter
tôt mais moins contaminé aussi alors
bertran auvert vous avez justement
amener un autotest c'est une nouveauté
de l'année de l'an passé les autotests
qu'on peut trouver en pharmacie vous
allez nous dire un peu à quoi ça sert
comment ça marche les exemplaires de
tests tout le monde peut acheter en
pharmacie on n'a pas besoin de redonner
donc ça on l'achète en pharmacie plus
simplement on va en formation demande à
un autre texte c'est extrêmement sain
donc on va faire un petit test en direct
c'est va le tester en direct ça peut
être anxiogène on est chez soi je romans
drôme et ses 110 ans le laboratoire
le laboratoire a à z et miles and avec
le soutien d'hachette prévention deux
aides et de sida info service
nous on a quand l'effectif on a fait la
conférence de presse de lancement on a
bien insisté sur le fait qu'il était
primordial que les gens puissent se
tester chez eux parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui ne veulent pas aller
voir une association comme hachette
prévention qui ne veulent pas aller en
centre de dépistage qui - sont en vie
c'est la honte vous avez mais je
connaissais bien les publics d'achève
prévention on est des spécialistes des
hommes ayant des relations sexuelles
avec d'autres hommes et des publics
invisible et notamment ses pères de
famille qui pour une relation
occasionnelle ou régulière vont
effectivement avoir des relations avec
d'autres hommes alors qu'ils ont une
femme des enfants etc
cette auto test ça permet quoi ça permet
qui vont dans une pharmacie
ils n'ont pas besoin d'en parler à un
médecin ils n'ont pas besoin d'en parler
à une association ils n'ont pas besoin
non plus de d'aller voir leur médecin
généraliste pour avoir donc un test en
la bourse est quand même les tests en
labo qui sont les plus répandus donc en
france faut pas l'oublier
pour le coup c'est une forme une chance
formidable qui est offerte aux gens de
pouvoir se tester chez eux pour un coût
qui avoisine entre 25 et 30 euros donc
une moyenne de
25,28 euros généralement nous on a
d'ailleurs fait un plaidoyer auprès de
la ministre
très récemment 3 les trois structures
associatives hf prévention sida info
service ais aide justement pour demander
la baisse de la tva sur cet outil parce
que c'est un outil qui est
complémentaire complémentaire à ce qui
est fait chez nous complémentaire à ce
qui est fait dans les centres de
dépistage et pour le coup c'est offrir
aux gens la chance de se dépister chez
eux comme ils le font aujourd'hui pour
d'autres maladies on va leur montrer
justement comment comment ça marche
alors allez-y donc vous avez mauvaise
que l'autotest au louvre on a une petite
capsule de dix ans que l'on met dans le
support en l'appuyant correctement voilà
vous avez un loto un autopiqueur alors
vous nettoyer un petit peu avec l'alcool
devant tout le monde avec de l'eau
chaude avant vous laissez bien séché de
l'alcool pour pas que ça a perturbé
perturbe l'autotest les voir c'est
extrêmement rapide voilà une fois que
l'alcool est sec
vous prenez l'autopiqueur d'appuyer bien
fort là vous avez une première goutte de
sang absolument pas mal voyez je n'ai
pas eu tord les boyaux les douleurs
voulait sous la table vous ou alors il a
recommandé donc de 2 et suit la première
goutte de sang et d'attendre la deuxième
alors s'il ne s'en vient pas on peut le
très légèrement pressé le doit prendre
la 2ème goutte de sang je ne sais pas si
les jambes
c'est une opération qui prend la france
revoie de voilà et ensuite mettre ça
dans la petite capsule en appuyant fort
et lustres en verre d'imagina
l'intérieur sur trois niveaux de
résistance voilà et à ce moment là il
faut attendre quinze minutes
alors qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe au bout de 15 minutes vous
voyez normalement si tout s'est bien
passé
vous voyez une offrira 15 minutes pas 25
minutes où vous vouliez une première
bande qui est la bande contrôle alors je
ne sais pas si les gens peuvent bien la
voir mais enfin on voit on voit une
bande contrôle qui apparaît voilà on
voit la bande contrôle rouge qui
apparaît et ça donc c'est la bande
contrôle et s'il ya une bande de tests
bon test en dessous qui apparaît c'est
que vous êtes un stage qui a déjà été
violemment
voilà c'est la razzia sur la table rase
et celui je me suis fait il ya quinze
minutes donc préalablement j'ai attendu
voilà donc voilà ce qu'on pourra voir
dans 15 minutes
si on attend qu'elle mais vous voyez que
c'est très simple c'est très simple
alors il faut il faut quand même dire un
tout petit mot sur ses limites
c'est pas un test exceptionnel pour
détecter les infections récentes est
plutôt un test qui est très bien pour
détecter les infections qui ne sont
apparus depuis un certain temps disons
de trois mois qui sont installés les
infections pas le lendemain d'une heure
là n'ont pas du tout les infections
récentes c'est par un test très bon pour
ça et s'il est positif
en plus c'est un test d'orientation il
faut aller le faire confirmer dorée
centres de dépistage je pense que benoît
sera décoré mais parfaitement d'accord
c'est ce qu'on est et à leur céder on a
plusieurs outils on allait s'en de
dépistage on allait tester konaté les
trolls ou courtisé par les options je
pense qu'à cas permis quand même de
démultiplier dépistage on a des
autotests moi j'appelle ça un outil un
outil au sens médical qui permet de
multiplier les offres et les
possibilités de dépistage et c'est ça
qui est important là après du médecin
associatif on connaît effectivement les
limites
il ya des limites pour l'auto test mais
ça permet à ce qu'on arrive pas encore
allé à chercher peut-être qu'il ya des
jeunes qui n'osent pas aller dans les
centres
et pourquoi pas mais il faut multiplier
pour pouvoir diminuer cette
contamination
justement on va on va insister sur les
jeunes avec d'autres chiffres 11 % des
nouvelles contaminations en france
concerne les 15 24 ans on voit là
également à l'écran 15 % des lycéens et
des étudiants pensent aujourd'hui que
guérir du sida n'est plus compliqué
grâce au traitement selon un sondage de
la de la smerep un étudiant sur trois
n'utilise jamais de préservatifs ça
c'est un autre ce sont d'autres chiffres
alarmants car la grossesse vous vous
êtes justement étudiantes alors je sais
pas si ces chiffres vous concerne
personnellement mais ce que autour de
vous je rappelle que vous êtes la
coréalisatrice d'un court métrage sur le
sida pour le concours vih pocket films
est-ce que vous dans votre entourage
vos amis votre classe à vous vous avez
le sentiment là que les jeunes on en
parle plus on n'est plus concerné ça ne
fait plus peur le sida clairement en ce
qui concerne la protection les
préservatifs etc
on a quand même un petit peu
l'impression que c'est rentré dans les
moeurs et s'est donc enfin autour de moi
en tout cas c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est hacké courant qui
est une pratique courante mais après ce
dont vous parliez de relâchement et
c'est d'avoir moins peur en fait tout
simplement puisque on se dit que on va
pas en mourir de toute façon que il y à
un traitement même si on n'est pas
soigné may un traitement donc
effectivement va effectivement il ya un
relâchement
comment on peut lutter contre ce
relation inscrits par exemple peut
imaginer des faisait pas des cours au
collège des cours ou au lycée alors
peut-être que le collège c'est trop tôt
ça va être un débat ça j'imagine mais au
lycée qu'est-ce qu'il faut imaginer ce
qu'on fait mais je le serai un mode de
jeu j'ai plus une avec plus dans les
yvelines donc on s'est rapprochés de nos
collègues médecins scolaires infirmières
scolaires ces infirmières scolaires sont
vraiment encore présente dans les
établissements est vraiment ce passage
d'information je vais parler d'éducation
à la santé mais là on peut parler
effectivement d'éducation pour pas que
ce soit un sujet tabou
donc pour que le jeune puisse en parler
à la collègue a fermé un éclat collègues
infirmières puissent répondre
bayal autotests cia le service de
dépistage il yal'association donc je
crois qu'il faut après des mots qu'on
n'aime pas bien faux
se responsabiliser et oui oui ça existe
ce qu'on n'a pas parlé et tout on le
sait bien parce qu'il ya une
recrudescence je suis optimiste mais il
ya quand même une recrudescence des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
qu'ils ont la syphilis la gonorrhée
aussi les chlamydias qu'on a découvert
il ya on a découvert ya longtemps mais
aujourd'hui on les recherche beaucoup
parce qu'on sait les conséquences
possibles
donc oui je suis optimiste mais c'est
pour justement que tout le monde vienne
où tout le monde se fait dépister et
dans les jeunes il faut continuer ça
doit faire partie absolument cette
d'éducation à la santé et la santé
sexuelle pour pas qu'ils une peur ou un
tabou de l'activité sexuelle les gens je
suis que médecin mais pour informer qu
aujourd'hui le meilleur moyen de
prévention et dépistage face et le
préservatif est avec le dépistage et à
relais d'information bertran auvert est
ce que les politiques par exemple ont un
rôle à jouer
est-ce que ils ne jouent plus leur rôle
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ont relâché la
pression aussi et que du coup ça ça
décline sur sur les jeunes sur leurs
parents je crois je crois pas moi que ça
soit un rôle que ce soir le chemin des
politiques je pense plutôt ceux qui
étaient dictées de l'heure c'est que
l'arrivée des antirétroviraux à
transformer notablement la maladie qui
est devenu une maladie chronique comme
le disait paul walker avec toc on en a
moins peur même si il faut se rend
compte de ce que c'est que la réalité
que vivre avec le virus et se faire
traiter c'est quand même prendre des
médicaments tous les jours que les
effets secondaires c'est une ville très
compliqué c'est pas du tout pas du tout
anodin change la toute petite chose ce
préservatif quand même faut se rendre
compte que si on assimile 600 nouveaux
cas de vih en france on en a vingt fois
plus
en ce qui concerne des infections
sexuellement transmissibles que vous
mentionnez c'est à dire que on a 75
mille cas de chlamydia dont certains
sont très durs très très difficile à
traiter attention voilà on a quinze
mille cas de gonococcie on a quinze
mille cas de syphilis on a six mille cas
de cancer du col parents on a 120 mille
cas globalement terre 20 fois plus de
cas hors locaux le préservatif quand
même protège au son du vih mais vendre
une partie même si pas parfait
très bonne protection contre de
nombreuses infections sexuellement
transmissibles ainsi que le premier en
gros une grossesse non désirée donc ccc
voilà il ya des prises de conscience
très importante à faire et je crois que
les messages éducatifs
je sais pas s'ils sont bien passées je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas mais je pense
qu'elles les accès c'est difficile après
jérôme andré oui c'est difficile parce
que on a un tabou de parler de santé
sexuelle c'est difficile c'est plus
facile de parler actuellement enfin mais
il faut le faire aussi sur la lutherie
sur l'alimentation a vu un gros travail
sur le mental c'est vrai que la santé
sexuelle il ya un peu de vie dans nos
petites erreurs il faut pas se fermer
les yeux dans nos cultures de vie
sociale c'est plus difficile de parler
de sexualité des fois en lice et il est
lui fier mais je vous ai dit vous avez
compris j'avais un caractère optimiste
les foyers mais après par derrière oui
ça veut dire qu'il faut rencontrer des
gens et re rencontrer les gens il faut
persuader nos médecins scolaires nos
infirmières scolaires les les proviseurs
de parler de cet enseignement à cette
éducation germandrée alors vous mettez
en place plein de plein de dispositif
notamment
surtout contrairement à ce qui est dit
là c'est que effectivement il faut avoir
aussi un courage politique
le sida c'est ni de gauche ni de droite
cependant il y à une association qui
s'appelle élus locaux contre le sida qui
est présidée par jean luc romero qui est
aussi président d'honneur d'achève
prévention et c'est vrai que c'est
important aussi que les politiques
mettent les moyens nécessaires à la fois
financiers mais pas seulement
c'est aussi des volontés politiques que
de pouvoir effectivement faire du
dépistage comme on le fait dans des
centres commerciaux qui sont
effectivement donc dans des milieux
ouverts ciblés comme on le fait dans des
universités
nous on pense aussi que un moment donné
il faut qu'il y ait de l'innovation et
pour qu'il y ait des innovations il faut
aussi qu'il ya un courage politique
un courage du ministère de la santé des
agences régionales de santé qui font
effectivement un travail formidable
un autre côté qui nous soutiennent
effectivement sur des évolutions futures
de la prévention type est un exemple de
de prévention 2.0 puisque ses tubes
s'est trouvé un préservatif c'est donc
une application mobile smartphone qui a
dépassé les cent mille donc
téléchargement ou plutôt personnes qui
vont dans leur poche donc l'application
mobile
ça permet à la fois de géolocaliser les
préservatifs autour de soi qu'ils soient
gratuits ou payants et ça permet aussi
de géolocaliser tous les lieux de
dépistage tous les cegid mais aussi tous
les lieux où il y a effectivement dû
trod le fameux tests rapides qui est
fait notamment par un chef prévention
est donc vous gêne je voulais
géolocalisés et vous savez
instantanément ou est ce que vous pouvez
faire un test soit immédiatement soit
dans les jours qui viennent et je pense
sincèrement que c'est par ses
innovations mais notamment aussi virus
war ou les opérations une minute pour
savoir qu'on arrivera demain à faire
prendre conscience aux jeunes et aux
moins jeunes en tout cas aux gens qui
prennent des risques que le sida n'est
pas une affaire que chez les gays et
qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi que
la population générale se disent que oui
elle peut être aussi largement
conservées concerné par tout ça alors on
va passer à un autre sujet puisque
lutter contre le sida c'est aussi lutter
contre les préjugés les stéréotypes les
idées reçues c'est l'objet de votre
court-métrage car la grossesse
en deux mots on va en voir quelques
images et cielecran racontez-nous de
quoi parle votre court-métrage en fait
nous quand on a voulu faire voulu faire
ce court métrage on s'est dit qu'on
était pas spécialiste de la maladie on
n'était pas médecin donc ce qu'on a
voulu montrer c'était les réactions que
pouvaient avoir les gens face à la
maladie au sein des jeunes parce que
nous sommes nous sommes jeunes mais et
donc les différentes fins les
discriminations les rêves de coupe le
doigt avec du verre qui saigne qui est
séropositive il ya des amis qui la
soutiennent et puis à ceux qui devront
encore plus il est assez naturel qu'ils
y ont pris effrayé et d'autre
carrément hostile tout ça c'est des
choses messieurs qui s'améliore
aujourd'hui ils sont encore persistante
je voudrais juste féliciter quand même
sidaction sur une chose qui est très
simple c'est que vih pocket c'est un
dispositif sidaction qui existe quand
même depuis plusieurs années et qui
permet notamment aux jeunes mais plus
largement aux enseignants aussi de
pouvoir parler du sida de mettre en
place dans les cours dans l'est dans les
classes le moyen de monter effectivement
c'est petit c'est nest et surtout de
parler de la maladie et c'est vrai que
pour le coup nombreux jeunes ont été
donc remercié par sidaction et on peut
retrouver effectivement c'est l'ensemble
de ses vidéos sur le site de sidaction
alors messieurs nous reste une minute je
vais partager 30 secondes et 30 secondes
le temps en deux on va commencer par
vous
bertran auvert sur faire de la
prévention auprès du public finalement
qui n'est pas à séropositif c'est ça
aussi la bataille d'aujourd'hui c'est
une partie de la bataille en tout cas
oui bien sûr et je fais d'accord ce le
rôle que joue sidaction dans ce domaine
ya aussi le rôle de l'année reste
recherché je crois qu'on a des équipes
de recherche formidable en france
concernant la prévention je parlais la
prévention pré exposition qui est quand
même une belle la france elle joue et en
particulier à la demande canalplay dans
laquelle la france a joué un rôle
considérable
je crois que là il faut remercier
sidaction une reste les acteurs français
les tours ce domaine benoît couvert ont
traité un acteur local de pour le
dépistage pour contre continuez donc le
dépistage ça se fait entre autres dans
des cegid mais je crois que cegid
effectivement doigt comme aujourd'hui
mais comment on fait avec la chef
prévention sortir de nos murs pour aller
rencontrer les populations rencontrent
les populations dans les lycées les
universités les campus etc pour leur
dire voilà il ya la prévention pour
éviter de munitions et pour produire des
pistes et vous donc les cegid j'espère
arriveront avec les autres
pour suivre ce dépistage est diminuée
d'épidémie merci à vous quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission on arrive au
terme malheureusement déjà de cette
émission pour faire un don pour le
sidaction c'est simple toutes les
informations s'affichent à l'écran par
téléphone au 110 ou sur internet
www.sidaction.org
sur internet vous pouvez également
retrouver cette émission en replay tv
fil 78 points comme bonne soirée à tous